sorry have you ever sold a reality TV
show just as a pitch there are reality
shows usually what I'll do is I'll
partner with a production company
because I don't have one and we'll go
out and we'll present that show together
most of the time shows are not bought in
the room although it has been known to
happen
there is a pretty sure that I worked for
who was on the phone with a major cable
network pitching a show that he had been
working on for weeks paused in the
middle of the conversation and said well
how about a show where this happens and
that happens and they liked it so much
this idea that they committed to the
idea on the phone this doesn't happen a
lot most of what's happening especially
with people who are mid-career and are
not yet captains in the business Mark
Burnett is going to have a very
different meeting that I'm going to have
I'm gonna meet with someone who's a
firewall between the person who's making
the decisions and me
whereas Burnett is going to meet with
you know probably talk to Les Moonves
and say I have another show for you when
you go in with those shows typically
what will happen is you'll have a little
bit of back-and-forth it doesn't get
bought in the room necessarily because
they're sort of testing the sea
worthiness of the idea to make sure that
you have something that's completely
saleable people come in with an idea
that's not finished or a concept for a
show that they that doesn't stand up to
questioning or you know sometimes the
executive might be trying to sort of
crush it into the form of something that
they need to buy at that time the
example that I always give is if I'm
pitching you a show where women are
trying to find love and the executive
says well you know we just got a sponsor
that's a motorcycle company can they be
trying to find love and be on a
motorcycle trip across the country at
the time this is happening
it's an exaggerated example but you're
right the thing that's supposed to
happen is you're not supposed to always
sell your show you're supposed to sell a
show a version of your show so that back
and forth is one of the reasons why I
don't think that there's always as a
sale in the room
right I know you talked about in another
interview the million dollar napkin
where people get this idea and maybe
they're having cocktails and hey
wouldn't this be great right so let's
say that person is somewhere maybe
they're selling real estate somewhere
they're selling insurance and they say I
want to pitch a reality show what what
are some cliff notes like just a quick
and dirty checklist I know you don't
like lists but no no okay I think I can
give you a checklist okay if you're
going to pitch a show the million dollar
napkin idea is that everybody thinks
that everything's so easy to sell like
hey it's about two guys that work in a
junkyard well you've got to understand
your talent so if you are someone who is
coming into this cold if you're pitching
a show about an occupation for example
make sure that you have people selected
that are viable cast for this show who
have agreed on paper to let you pitch a
show about them for a period of time so
that when you walk in the room even if
they don't like the people you have they
see that you are able to put that talent
together it's very hard for someone who
is brand new to sell a format if you
were selling a reality competition show
or anything where the format is the star
as opposed to the talent being the star
you're gonna have a very hard time doing
that because there are people who are
completely dedicated to creating those
types of shows and you yourself do not
bring value to that show as a creator
you have to figure out how to package
things out a little bit and to figure
out how to add value to yourself so
really think about it also when you go
in be sure you have an idea especially
if you're doing a doc your soap
docu-series have an idea of who you want
to cast and also have an idea of where
that show could go over a period of two
or three seasons just so they know again
it's that that it's something that's
that's built to last and there's
somewhere to take you as opposed to
showing you a bunch of interesting
people who aren't necessarily doing
lunch and that would be the short
checklist the longer checklist I think
is making sure that the idea that you
have is not only saleable and
in line with a particular networks needs
or wants don't create a show because you
think it would be fun
create a show that has a buyer in mind
think if you want to create a show
that's just completely different and I
know because I've learned this from
doing it myself their shows I'm very
passionate about that just don't have a
home because no network is carrying the
kind of thing that I wanted to do don't
go into the wrong place or you've
completely torpedoed your relationship
with them forever is you come in the
door with something that is so foreign
to their network you've wasted their
time it looks like you don't know what
you're doing it looks like you haven't
bothered to look into what they do and
they don't want to see you again
Wow so be incredibly prepared it sounds
like be incredibly prepared take the
time to research the networks that would
like to see the kind of programming that
you're bringing in make sure that you're
not creating a show that is cost
prohibitive to the point where the
example that I often give is I call it
celebrity choir it's if you had a if you
had to do a show or every episode a
celebrity has to get twenty other
celebrities together and form a choir
and you're gonna do eight eight episodes
over a season that's a hundred and
sixty-eight celebrities that you would
have to have involved in that show over
the season
now it's celebrity choir a good idea if
I just have one celebrity who has to get
a group of normal people together and
figure out how to lead them as a choir
sure because then you have eight people
that you need to cast over the season
instead of a hundred and sixty eight and
suddenly that show is a sellable doable
thing which leads me back to something
else I heard you say that just because
maybe your two neighbors down the street
are totally fascinating and you want to
sell this idea about their lives
whatever it is doesn't mean it's gonna
fly that they really do want people that
have some kind of a following well I
don't know that that's necessarily true
if you are presenting a show and you
just have some people who are
interesting or have an unusual lifestyle
we have really gotten into in the last
couple of years shows that are very big
on people who is who have unusual
occupations or people who have unusual
family dynamics hoarders and things
exactly those are actually great so you
can sell a show about the folks down the
street the only thing that you've got
do is make sure that there is a cut that
there is a way to make sure that there
is story that could happen to those
people every week there are people who
are interesting and then there are
people that you want to follow there's a
difference I've had some great
conversations with people that are fun
to talk to for an hour but I want to I
don't want them in my living room you
know 15 times a season you know not
getting much accomplished so going back
to making sure that there is talent
attached whether it's a big name or
somebody down the street what is that
exactly is that a contract and what does
that look like usually what you'll do is
you'll have some sort of an arrangement
with your talent that basically says
that you have the exclusive right to
pitch a show with them attached to it
for a specific period of time for me
typically it's about a hundred and
twenty days at the outside some people
will do it longer some people will do it
shorter I think it gives you enough time
that you can take it out once because
once it's been around the idea is kind
of exhausted once a series has been
pitched word gets around everybody knows
that it's been out so you don't really
you've really got you know one shot to
take it somewhere so 120 days is usually
long enough to do it and basically all
you're doing is preventing production
companies and other people from doing an
endzone run around you and just going
directly to your talent and saying you
know it's great that Fred introduced us
but I think we can do the show without
Fred so why don't you come with me and
we'll do the show and it has been known
to happen
you